hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the cursed
forest this amazing haha beautiful game
now you may be wondering why I'm
starting here and not over there where I
was it's because someone wrote me a very
strong email calling me numerous
colorful names that I am rushing this
game and missed the scare in this house
I don't know how I actually feel like
I'm taking this very meticulously
however I will reproach it again and go
towards the house and look for a scare I
thought I found him with you know what
with the shadows and all that but
apparently there is a big one here that
is not currently explored its I had to
play through this game again because
there's no same mechanic so I didn't see
that before but was that it oh that's
the breathing I heard I see what
happened I picked up the note
accidentally my hand spasm didn't hit
the button Oh
died oh good I was worried cuz I mean
there was no save mechanic - yeah before
I had to play through it okay that's
good oh okay so that was the breathing
that I heard you douchebag why would you
do that why would you decide there okay
so there hahaha you had your fun oh no
mr. woolsley is gonna get me oh no he
climbed up there only an idiot would
just stick his face up in the ceiling
where he was okay so that's past
he's killed me once whereas I was not
going to be killed before you know who
you is you know who you are okay so now
we're we're gonna venture down here and
I guess we're gonna go in the river
which probably will lead my instant
death if I'm not mistaken but it seems
to be where the lighted path wants to
take me let's uh let's go in
hope that was me solution my way
downtown walking fast moving past and
I'm home bound okay okay oh it's the
lady of the Swan no that's not a lady
that's not a lady
Oh run and don't look back at the shadow
hey I can't run this is my top speed
really this is what tough speed
I wanna look back kinda oh but I just
died I won't waste more time can I just
say this is the least dramatic chase
I've ever been on in my entire life oh
oh no I'm running as fast as I can
I guess it's over I'm sorry I have to
laugh that was the most meandering pace
I've ever seen a monster chase in my
entire life and I was booking it you
could tell out I'm holding down all the
buttons I I hope I hope I'm not looking
like a fool and there was actually a
sprint button anyway let me uh and
there's a path that goes up there but
I'm gonna just look over here for just a
second just in case there's something
that it wants me to find which I'm
assuming if there's a lot of hidden
nooks and crannies around this plate
okay see how this is oh I thought those
was eyes for perfection my second first
Jackie I thought I saw some eyes I just
allowed to go up here I don't even know
where I'm going I can't even see
anything it's all dark it's like some
ledges but I don't I can't oh I can jump
I didn't think I could jump okay I can
jump but not sprint uh I don't know what
it wants from me what's up here is
anything up here his eye fell okay okay
there's an invisible wall okay do I
can't go up there fine
I'm trying to explore I'm trying to be
very meticulous about this game because
there's a lot of things in this game
there's so much detail and like I said
before I had to play through the game
again and it's weird playing a horror
game and not saying anything
because there's a lot of nuances that I
miss when I'm just kind of talking and
when I was playing it alone it was very
good god damn it
Oh another invisible wall fine I should
okay from now on I just follow the fires
because I don't think there's anything
else that I need to find unless I missed
something which I don't think that I did
okay enough wasting time I gotta get
through this oh it's did enough time as
it is alright bring it on you evil black
thing I thought it was a werewolf at
first but it just look like a skinny
dude a skinny shadowy dude
no werewolf here bring it on do you see
me I'm 200 Jones
did you get me Oh didn't get me okay
that was cool
where'd it go this is vanished I think
okay oh okay
something doesn't want me to come up
here I wonder what secrets you're hiding
your shadowy porn collection it's like
some sort of building was here but now
it's destroyed maybe was I gonna keep
look how pretty that is
ah I keep I'm getting paranoid because
I've noticed especially when I was
playing through it again I've noticed it
the eyes are there and almost every
single location I was if I made a 360 I
could find them okay so yeah this is
like oh this is like a tower something
something Hey oh there we go
I gotcha red red red red red gotta
follow the light at all points gotta
follow the light okay so I got a stone
last time oh they didn't even bother
with separating this one just a hold
poor's Oh with spine like that go down
here whoa oh is he nearby
oh man that I didn't even notice that
the trees move that's creepy
okay so I'm going down the ledges okay I
don't know if a fall will kill me oh oh
that hurt oh yeah
okay gotcha all right so I'm gonna
follow this down okay that is the house
that I was just at and gotten brutally
Myrtle eyes I had my intestines ripped
out through my larynx that is not fun
let me go somewhere or opened passage it
said it again in wonderful English so so
what about that
so that gonna fall on my head I see you
know I don't see you but I mean I see oh
oh no that's the tower that's weird I
couldn't even notice that but did I
notice that on the way and I don't think
I did might not have been on there's so
much detail in this game just so many
intricate little things that I've missed
what is that red is he red what is that
okay no I thought I saw like a shadowy
figure don't tell me that you guys
didn't see that - that tree stump right
there what the hell is this
are you hungry
hey Apple replace me doesn't seem like a
good idea
I'm gonna guess no hmm that's yummy in
my tummy come on can't believe you you
ass oh I'm all the way up here
fine I'll be right back Wow
running around or speed of sound
okay how about no on that one okay so I
need to follow the second path I
actually thought that when I was high up
that I might be coming down this
particular Hill but apparently that is a
note so anyway moving on now
why would they put the check you have
not collected all the necessary okay is
that Apple part of the necessary fine
I'll go the other way good for me I'll
be completely oblivious and okay so I'm
back now
don't ask what I was doing because I
don't even know myself now I'm walking
down the other path that I apparently
have all the requisites to go down
there's a lot of arbitrary rules in this
game
that a car should I go check that out
you gotta kill me here okay
just glad you didn't arbitrarily kill me
out of spite okay moving on now I'm
playing your game you rogue and I still
don't know the rules but I'm playing it
I just pick up the pace I swear I just
went faster all of a sudden that's what
I'm doing I'm going faster I am I'm
going blazing speed did I just hit my
Run button somehow
oh that doesn't sound good
where the hell am i oh oh no oh this is
bad what do I need to do it's a bog a
swamp there's nothing bad if the water
isn't there okay
oh I see red okay okay go wait what is
that it's moving
is that a bad red I'm gonna assume
that's a bad red let's go before me oh
hey I'm assuming I need to not fudge bad
cover for me okay maybe not oh okay
just give me my eyes and a leg bone give
me that I'm out of here baby I'm out I'm
Audi okay
don't see it it's coming for me
it's angry it's coming for me oh it's
coming for me
no does it know does it I don't want to
die again okay damn it I think I'm good
I think I'm good all right so I got two
arms a hip bone a torso with spine and
how the hell did I okay over here and
now I got one leg I only need one more
leg and a head and I think I'm done I
think why are you watching me you have
habit of watching me who's coming for me
okay gonna have to do better than that
like clawing me to death eviscerated me
ripping my head off hanging me from the
tallest tree throwing me off a mountain
crushing me with a boulder crushing me
with a tree or feeding me a bad apple
come on you gotta do better than that
somewhere open the passage oh good I'm
so happy I'm assuming that meant that I
need to go uphill now is that [ __ ]
with the Apple still there yep
he still thinks he can get me but I'm
I'm too smart for him I'm far too smart
and by too smart I mean I'm
exceptionally dumb those like a own
award ceremony for the dumbest people I
was the only one dumb enough to show up
okay okay I can't go up there now okay I
don't know where there's leading me and
I don't know how much longer is in the
game I only need to collect like the
head and the foot this is more no torso
spine hip arm arm leg I just need the
head and the other other leg I'm almost
done I think unless I somehow need more
than
what is that glowing what is it
what is it who's a teddy bear why is out
there it's gonna turn around and look at
me
oh I blinked turn around you did you
[ __ ]
I knew you would something flew by my
head - okay
got a cup for me like it all there's so
much woods there's so much wood oh I
just got to say I had a bad oh okay I
blinked again I don't see it okay good
good that's good that's good that's good
that's good teddy bear Doom is clone
after my botox that's okay I'm okay
I think I escaped it good good good good
good good
what is that do I need that is that the
skull it looks like it might be the
school Oh some Mel what is that I'm sort
of crystal was that crying or laughing
you son of a [ __ ] how was I supposed to
know the difference
where am i okay
think ID to go this way oh good that one
you decided that I needed to be close to
okay thank you sure I touch it oh well
everybody I'm gonna touch I'm taking my
headphones off so I don't get jumpscared
oh I'm turning up the volume oh it's
gonna happen now no no no now it's about
time that you guys enjoyed the terror of
this game okay I see a light over there
I'm probably gonna stop right there
because I'm think I'm running out of
time well that almost looks downright
cheerful look at all this look at all
this god there's so much I love it I
absolutely look why did those fireflies
oh wait a minute did time just freeze or
was that just me the time really just
freeze okay I can't open that some sort
of electric generator in here okay
anyway I'm gonna pause it here cuz I'm
all the time for this one so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]
[Applause]
find those boxes
chi'lan